bonjour max orville bonjour maurizio le
tombeau jour aux auditeurs de martinique
1ère et bonne journée
le modem le mouvement démocrate dont
vous êtes le président ici en martinique
est dans les starting blocks et
quasiment fait ça y est françois bayroux
est en marche pour la présidence et il a
laissé très clairement entendre ce matin
encore c'était sur les ondes de france
télévisions eh bien écoutez c'est vous
qui le dites tant qu'il n'aura pas donné
leurs responsabilités de départ ça fait
un moment qu'il le dit oui maintenant
effectivement il à vous le savez lancer
un nouvel ouvrage de puits la semaine
dernière qui présente une vision de la
france en général ce qu'on fait
lorsqu'on est candidat
nous verrons en tout cas nous sommes
prêts à tout cas françois bayrou s'est
montré que se battre est très sévère
avec françois fillon accusé d'être sous
influence des puissances d'argent
oui effectivement il y a de quoi être
navré j'entendais tout à l'heure jean
marc parti dans son éditorial qui
retraçait également ce phénomène auquel
nous assistons depuis 15 jours il n'y a
plus de débat d'idées tout est focalisé
sur les émoluments distribués de manière
discrétionnaire par françois fillon à sa
famille son épouse ses enfants et pour
des sommes qui ma foi ne sont pas des
petites sommes pour le martiniquais qui
touche entre 500 et 600 euros
les sommes qu'on entend frise
l'indécence et puis sa société de
conseil
zf conseil à se lancer cette assurance
est une menace sur la démocratie menace
pour la démocratie devant l'ampleur de
cette cette influence des puissances
d'argent
mais effectivement normalement la
démocratie la responsabilité politique
devrait être à l'abri de ces dérives
financières
or aujourd'hui à quoi nous assistons
nous voyons très nettement des candidats
je ne dirais pas acheter mais en tout
cas
aidés par des grosses entreprises
économique et cetera pour pouvoir faire
de l'entrisme et obtenir effectivement
un certain nombre davantage ceci est
tout à fait scandaleux il n'est pas
conforme à ce que ne passe que à l'idée
que nous nous faisons de la démocratie
que tentera de faire françois bayrou il
ira à la présidentielle en tentant de
récupérer non seulement ses partisans du
centre mais également les déçus de la
droite et de la gauche
je pense que si françois bayrou se
présente c'est pour essayer de donner un
cap essayer de rassembler tous les
français autour de deux principes
simples il faut retrouver une unité dans
ce pays il faut une démocratie
institutionnelle des toiles étaient plus
transparente plus respectueuse de la
population face à des jeunes sans
emmanuel macron bah écoutez il prend
très bien la lumière
on ne connaît pas son projet et le fait
de dire je ne suis pas de gauche je ne
suis pas de droite en fonction des
options des réponses dans les sondages
écoutez là encore je vous renvoie votre
rédacteur jean-marc partie les sondages
d'un jour ne sont pas les sondages du
lendemain est depuis quelques mois on
assiste amusé à ce spectacle navrant des
sondages qui met le premier qui
deviennent derniers soutiens ici de
d'emmanuel macron une macro magna qui
frappe dans notre île que pensez-vous
des soutiens qu'il a obtenu en
martinique
comment les choses se passent pour vous
comment voyez-vous tout cela c'est
certains de nos élus estiment que si le
bon wagon à prendre aujourd'hui je ne
vois pas ça en termes d'opportunités et
apparemment je vois des opportunités il
y a des gens qui appartiennent à des
partis y en a qui attendait peut-être
jusqu'au dernier moment pour dire c'est
le bon wagon et c'est non pour l'instant
emmanuel macron je les écoutais samedi
attentivement dans son meeting à lyon
c'était une très belle dissertation
philosophique sur la liberté l'égalité
la fraternité mais malheureusement je
n'ai rien entendu concernant l'outre-mer
singulièrement et de plus je n'ai rien
vu comme perspective alors d'eau qui
paraît que son programme va sortir fin
mars
notre désir pratiquer notre classe
politique
max orville notre classe politique d'un
parti nick était exempt de tout reproche
au moment au plan national la micra même
cette sacrée distance qui se creuse
entre les élus et le reste de la
population
je crois que nous sommes également
frappé que la classe politique ne répond
peut-être pas à la demande de la
population
je vois que la course aux législatives
est déjà lancé je vois des candidats qui
sont actuellement investis dans des
instances importante où il y a à peine
un an et demi ont juré croix de bois
croix de fer si je meurs je vais en
enfer je serai celui qu'il va m'attarder
à m'occuper de la martinique uniquement
de la martinique
et dès la première élection eh bien on
est candidat donc s'ils sont déjà
fatigués usés après un an et demi à la
gouvernance de la ctm notamment bas
qu'ils le disent parce qu à quoi ça sert
d'aller se présenter à des élections
nationales alors que votre mandat celui
que vous avez sol et responsabilités en
aval l'autre il y a une responsabilité
mais ce n'est pas le même travail
on y reviendra le respect de la
responsabilité de déo législatif c'est
d'être avant tout un élu de la nation
avant d'être un élu martiniquais
en martinique on va parler de cet
article de cette interview parue dans
france antilles le 19 janvier dernier
une interview de marine est à torpiller
conseillère exécutive en charge du
développement économique
et ça vous fait tiquer vous max orville
à parce qu'elle a elle a affirmé être
dans une démarche avec l'état pour que
les dettes sociales et fiscales des
entreprises hôtelières j'crois soir h et
quitte à être remboursé un petit peu
plus tard et manifestement vous prenez
le même pli que l'association des
consommateurs et des citoyens de la
caraïbe et vous dit que ça ne semble pas
être très clean tout cela pour quoi
écoutez encore une fois la ctm a tout à
fait le conseil exécutif a tout à fait
le droit de choisir ses priorités
mais encore faut-il que sur des sujets
je crois aussi essentiel
lorsqu'on décide de racheter les dettes
sociales et fiscales d'entreprises
privées la moindre des choses c'est
d'expliquer à la population
sur quels critères vous choisissez vos
priorités
pourquoi l'hôtellerie plutôt que le btp
il au secteur ou par du sang pour le
développement économique de la marque
que le le secteur porteur ce n'est pas
que le tourisme
il y a aussi les transports il ya aussi
des petits artisans qui concourt à faire
de notre île
quelque chose de beau et d'agréable à
venir visiter par exemple mais tous les
secteurs économiques sont au rouge
sur quels critères vous le faites alors
donc ça c'est le premier point le second
point c'est tout simplement de ne pas
risquer comme on l'entend un ben tiens
il y a quelqu'un qui a la ctm a des
relations ou par le passé a eu des
relations avec l'hôtellerie bri bien
change aux bergers non je veux dire par
là c'est qu'il est il est clair non mais
pour moi je veux dire je veux pas me
jeter l'anathème sur calcul sur
quiconque
au contraire c'est plutôt les préserver
je pense que des décisions aussi
importantes de vision des choses très
clairement banques sauvées sur vos vous
accuse de riez l'actuelle conseillère
exécutive en charge du développement
économique et de demander des décisions
qui arrangerait yan monplaisir qui était
connu pour dans le secteur de
l'hôtellerie non je dis simplement que
pour être tout à fait transparent et ne
pas avoir une nouvelle affaire ou green
parrot ou une question comme françois
fillon et avec tout ce qu'il est
confronté
je demande simplement qu'on nous
explique les raisons pour lesquelles un
choix a été fait dans quelles conditions
est ce qu il a fait l'objet de débats
est liée à une assemblée
alors je suis très à l'aise pour dire
que l'assemblée de la martinique ce ne
doit pas être une assemblée croupion
c'est une assemblée législative c'est
une assemblée qui doit formuler des
propositions et qui donc a son mot à
dire sur tout ce qui se passe or
aujourd'hui aucune plénière à ma
connaissance n'a eu lieu
sur ce débat encore une fois vous
choisissez l'hôtellerie tant mieux mais
fait de même en la qualification je
demande une clarification fait ça en
grand je veux savoir
on pense que ces deux dates tout un
discrédit encore sur la classe politique
mais tout à fait remarquer il ne faut
pas faire les choses en bas feuilles le
citoyen martiniquais doit être un
citoyen averti
il doit être un citoyen a visé tout tous
les éléments du débat doivent être sur
la table et comme annoncé que vous et je
l'association des consommateurs disent
fait de la clarée qui se posent la
question
ça me passe comme une lettre à la poste
que d'espoir qui justement justement cet
article de l'association des
consommateurs et cette interview du 19
janvier
apparemment et est restée lettre morte
ça de conséquence monsieur viol temps et
nous le voyons de plus en plus de
citoyens s'engagent dans des élections
législatives pour représenter le citoyen
de plus en plus d'associations comme
cette association de consommateurs
attire l'attention sur ce qui se passe
est de plus en plus le citoyen pourrait
pourrait déposer plainte contre une
décision qu'ils estiment arbitraire
parce qu'il faut bien rappeler une chose
il s'agit d' âge d'argent public c'est
votre argent c'est le mien nous devons
savoir comment sont utilisés les sommes
du coup du contribuable et r je voyais
j'entendais sur votre antenne le
président de la ctm rouspéter à juste
titre contre le contrat de maintenance
du tcsp en qualifiant sa d'exorbitant il
défend les intérêts des martiniquais ils
essayent d'obtenir le juste prix eh bien
nous voulons que toutes les décisions
qui concernent l'avenir de la martinique
le budget de la martinique sera discuté
en plénière exactement ma soeur ville il
ne resterait peu de temps cette thèse du
monsieur pro plus propre les autres vous
allez y aller aux législatives pour
proposer ce martiniquais
le modem est prêt les quatre candidats
sont prêts nous attendons le top départ
de notre candidat merci d'avoir été ce
matin avec nos max orville en rappel
vous êtes le président du modem
martinique merci d'avoir été ce matin
dans son caddie
[Musique]